in doing damn near anything when it
comes to a man cheating on them like for
example
um Wendy Williams made a joke about
chopping a man's off
um on national TV and no one cared
um because a girl chopped her um
basically a girl chopped her partner's
like off and
um Wendy Williams basically and said oh
he deserved it
but if the roles were reversed like a
dude chopped you know our stuff off it
wouldn't be the same
women women get uh less time in prison
usually as well
yeah when it when it gets to being in
charge and being uh a similar crimes yes
uh it's like three times the amount of
sentencing for the same crime yeah I
don't get it I think naturally but just
because physically we're more vulnerable
I mean I don't think we I don't think it
should be it's not it's not solicited at
all I mean a crime is a crime
man or woman whatever but um
it's
physically we're more vulnerable so it's
a bit like
oh if he's cheated on me like
will I hit him
if I do like
so like not me that's not I don't know
me personally yeah
if you get if your boyfriend cheated on
you how would you react
I think women we have an upper hand in
more
um
have it created more mind [ __ ] like
emotionally mentally like letting them
using your words so would you would you
be spiteful enough no best friend or
something no no no no that that's like
that's like scoring our own goal like
what like there's that's no I would
probably do something worse no do
something that would actually let him
know yeah you [ __ ] up okay like leave
and cut contact meant I feel like men
they learn through through pain or men
learn through absence if someone's got
access to me he's
realistically is thinking yeah I know I
know her they start the other but rather
like I'm still trying to right now no
you need to cut all contacts and that's
it you need to put him on timeout and
that's with your absence is when a guy
will really feel like whoa what am I
doing like I feel I feel like she's not
talking to me she's not talking to me oh
my God like it's a rule this time she's
really pissed off
yeah
but I think in reference to the question
I think
this is this is the this is how
successful feminine feminism has been in
society and it's that kind of century
order the society has now become
part of it is down to the like the
feminist agenda but it's also down to
men overcompensating for what women
perceive the patriarchy have been so I
think a lot of women are unappreciative
of what men have done to propel Society
into where it currently is so feminism
has managed to Garner quite a lot of
strength in terms of changing people's
social perceptions to how men and women
deal with each other and in order for
men not to be considered misogynistic or
I guess be ostracized from society they
overcompensate for a lot of the things
that women do so a lot of things be
overlooked like I talk like I remember
bringing up a story in the podcast
before about when I was like s Aid and
it was funny to everyone
but if like if and it was funny to me as
well don't get me wrong because I never
felt at fret like it is what it is but
flip that over and put that same
scenario but as a woman it's game over
to basically give context like a woman
like ripped open my Robin and one bit my
chest was my Willy's all out and blah
blah blah but like if I was to go to
woman in the night out I bought a span
of a rip open a dress and then my friend
sakatiki
yeah it's gone left no no no I agree I
agree that this should be taken like
they're both the same degree of like
they're both the same thing like when
one Jenner does one thing and the same
gender does the same thing with sa it's
both should be taken like with the same
gravity I feel so I think a lot of women
say that though but I think in in
reality I don't believe a lot of you
but I know what you want to say here you
want to say like women don't see to the
same gravity but I also feel like
I don't want to like make mend the
victim again in this situation but I do
feel like men do enable certain things
like that because you see a lot of times
on like Twitter or online that you see
that men like lose their virginity to
really older women
um but in the present when that happened
a lot of the friends these male friends
were enabling that like oh like you've
seen a mill if you're doing this and
this and this and they don't actually
recognize you know within their group of
men that what they was doing or what
they were enabling was actually
something really messed up I mean you
don't you don't think women kind of do
the same thing when we're twerking
online when like any grown man can see
that or like your 15 year old dressed in
damn near nothing what do you think
you're attracting
I don't know what you're asking me so
I'm saying wouldn't you say like women
enable it too
I guess so I guess a certain degree yeah
I guess to a certain degree I'm not
saying that women don't like I'm talking
about them
the subjective male experience because
you're talking about your essay
experience I'm talking to how um it just
comes under that category it comes under
that category
um but like I feel like um with the Mad
experience and things like that happen
like sexually as well I feel like
sometimes the male Community also does
enable certain things by making certain
things
um elusive like I want to date an older
woman I want to have these experiences
like you'll see like men will try to get
into clubs really young I try to go to
certain parties really young because
they want to meet older women or I don't
know see I don't think the problem is
that men enable it because I think for
the most part it's it's weirdly a
privileged position to be in considering
that most men don't have access to sex
in the first place so it's being a
position with women what you that much
they're willing to do that to you is
probably a privileged position for a man
so I wouldn't say most men complain
about that I think the problem is is
that when women seek the so-called
equality then don't want to live by
equal standards that's when it becomes
problematic so the only reason I bring
up that point is because when women talk
about equality you only speak in terms
of double standards that suit you and
when it doesn't suit you you no longer
want it anymore
it depends on what topics though because
we're equal but men or women no but men
I mean as humans we are but men and
women are different we have different
needs like even with this Modern Woman
women thing like I think is I don't
think more and more women should try to
become more masculine I think women need
to embrace uh their own femininity and
understand the power in that instead of
trying to be this you know what you're a
go-getter I'm gonna be a go-getter
Resort I'm going to take on your role as
well like no we have our separate we
have our separate roles in the world uh
whether or not people wanna
uh understand that or not because yeah
we're equal but to a certain extent it
doesn't mean you're more important I'm
more important but just unfortunately we
have different roles like they say uh
women and children are the only people
that are loved unconditionally whereas
men they love conditioning on what you
can do on the action you take on how you
built like you said we just have I guess
we're born of like indefinite value
whereas men got judged on like who are
you what have you done what can you
provide etc etc do you think that will
stay the same though because I feel like
it's like that because Society is built
in a way where traditionally men were in
the workforce and traditionally member
seniors providers
so member scenes as a means to work when
someone's a means to work they're a
means to provide that's why they were
loved conditionally as many of you know
I was just banned on Tick Tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible